take you to some breaking news now
actually if you are eurovision fans
you'll be very pleased to hear that the
2023 eurovision song contest will be
hosted in the uk
next year on behalf of ukraine it's
going to be the 67th eurovision song
contest not the first time actually the
uk stepped in to be a host when the
original host nation has not been able
to to take uh to take the contest on the
european broadcasting union and the bbc
saying they're pleased to confirm that
the song contest will take place next
year following of course regrettably the
decision that the event can't be held in
ukraine for obviously safety and
security reasons the ebu has explored a
number of options with the winning
broadcaster and as a result of
discussions the bbc which of course uk
being a runner-up
in the 2022 contest was invited to be
the host broadcaster they go on to say
they are exceptionally grateful the bbc
is accepted to stage the eurovision song
contest and as i just mentioned the bbc
has taken on her duties for other
winning countries on four
previous occasions